Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and i been through some shit
(some shit)
but now baby i'm back
alright so i made the mistake
of wasting some time
well, i thank you for your noble sacrifce
i'm smart, i'm smaaaart
and i've been through some shit
YOINK
let's do this, i'm ready
i am so down for this
Ooh, Ooh, Ohh, Ooh
don't mind if i doo - Oo - Ooh
dopamine is rushing through my little brain
Hello, Oh, Oh
here i go, Oh, Oh
i am so down for this today
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
on a roll
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
and out of control
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
GERONIMO
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
i am so down for this today
i am so smart 2x
i am big smart 2x
my big brain
always working
getting me where i need to go
i am on a roll
i am feeling great
feeling fresh
gimme that key
that is what i need
i'm doing great
am i just gonna re doing this all eternity?
that's how it's gonna be
nay (no) i say
for me
and my dreams
have i finally grown taller?
this hallway seems smaller
i'm the biggest baby around
ain't nobody gonna stop me now
Ooh, Ooh, Ohh
don't mind if i do - Oo - Ooh
dopamine is rushing through my little brain
Hello, Oh, Oh
here i go, Oh, Oh
i am so down for this today
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
on a roll
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
and out of control
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
GERONIMO
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
i am so down for this today
make it four
on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur
get on the floor
open the door
everybody do the dinosaur
make it four
on the floor
everybody do the dinosaur
get on the floor
open the door
everybody do the dinosaur
Ooh , Ooh, Ooh
don't mind if i do - Oo - Ooh
dopamine is rushing through my little brain
Hello, Oh, Oh
here i go, Oh, Oh
i am so down for this today
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
on a roll
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
and out of control
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
GERONIMO
I'M BACK, BABY
BABY, I'M BACK
i am so down for this today
touch that box
YOINK
to get that track
Oh
so when you wake up in the mornin
you can say BABY, I'M BACK
love Mark and Schmo
Oh
now we've got to go
unless you put this on a replay loop (how? right click mouse in this videos and click loop)
then it's a never-ending show